when you swim into one of these Springs
and then a manatee comes around the
corner it's like everything slows down
and takes a breath it sometimes will
swim right up to you where you can count
the whiskers on its face or see the
propeller marks on its back it's got 20
manatees right down here I'm an eighth
generation Floridian I still feel like
I'm connected to the Florida from the
1800's through the stories of my
grandparents and great-grandparents and
I feel responsibility for the future of
Florida because of my heritage and
connection the Florida Wildlife Quarter
expeditions were not an arbitrary walk
in the woods we were following the paths
of wildlife as determined by the latest
research trying to bring attention to
the corridors that Wildlife need to move
from one place to another I was gonna
crush your camera on the trail today I
really don't think that's gonna happen I
think in all of its identity as a
tourist destination as the place of
amusement parks as a place of beaches
the identity of the heart of Florida
really gets lost
awesome but it's still here and it's
still beating absolutely amazing to be
here I don't think very many people know
this place exists
you don't have to go on a thousand-mile
expedition to be a conservation
photographer you can find a place that
you love right in your own backyard
go out photograph it share it tell its
story and you'll be surprised the amount
of change you can help create
you